one of the arguments you hear a lot in
the debate over gender ideology across
the political spectrum is that adults
should be able to do what they want you
know this is the supposedly moderate
position several presidential candidates
believe it millions of Americans believe
it too as long as you stay away from the
kids they tell you then there's no
problem
the moment you hit 18 years old do what
you want Live Your Truth it's not hard
to see why that position is tempting for
some people children obviously can't
consent to life-altering procedures
including genital mutilation and
castration especially those adults on
the other hand are able to consent to a
lot of things they can buy guns they can
vote they can serve in the military so
if they want to pay a doctor to carve up
their bodies then what's the big deal
that's the argument you hear again and
again
no one really means it though and you
know that no one means it because none
of the people making that argument would
use that same reasoning to justify say
lobotomies if you walked into a doctor's
office today and asked him to drill a
hole in your head in several sever your
prefrontal cortex in order to make you
feel better about your life he would say
no and if he did it he would go to
prison
no amount of informed consent no matter
how old you were could possibly justify
it it's barbaric tens of thousands of
people's lives were ruined by lobotomies
and everybody recognizes that now
nobody's marching in defense of lobotomy
affirming care so if you defend these
gruesome quote unquote gender affirming
procedures on adults you're not really
saying that adults should be able to do
what they want you're saying that yes
people can change their sex if they want
you're conceding that these procedures
slicing up a woman's arm to make a fake
penis lopping off healthy breasts
grafting fake nipples onto patients
chest Etc are medically reasonable
and in the absence of any kind of
statistical data about positive
long-term outcomes of these surgeries
you're trusting the doctors to follow an
established standard of care you're
assuming that they're not going to just
mutilate anyone who walks in the door
without regard for what happens to these
people afterwards
problem is that the entire industry of
gender affirming care is a scam
the whole thing
and we know that because we just spent
weeks investigating the largest
providers of so-called trans Health Care
in the country we went undercover at one
of them
and what we found is that there are no
real standards of care governing any of
this
to be clear there are standards of care
quote unquote on paper and they're
provided by the transgender activist
group wpath wpass standards are used by
Major hospitals in this country
including UCLA UCSF Mass general just to
name a few
how rigorous are these standards exactly
well after a 22 minute video call the
largest trans healthcare provider in the
country carefully following the wpath
guidelines approved one of my producers
Greg Ray for an orchiectomy that means
testicle removal
now 22 minutes would be a record time to
get approved for an archiectomy if you
had a real medical reason for it like
testicular cancer
it's insane to approve any serious
procedure that quickly having just met a
patient in a video call for the first
time but that's what happened and we
recorded the whole call
at no point did anyone at this
healthcare provider which is called
plume push back in any way they didn't
suggest that maybe this was a rash
course of action they didn't verify any
of the information Greg provided
including his fake name that he gave
them
all plume did was insist that he'd pay
150 bucks
if Greg did that they promised to write
him a medically sound letter in support
of life-altering surgery
that letter under the wpass standards is
required for anyone trying to get
transgender surgery in the United States
you have to get one of these letters
from a healthcare provider and then
present it to your surgeon and plume
rubber stamped Greg's letter in 22
minutes
and not all that time was spent
discussing the surgery by the way some
of the conversation was about traffic
and the weather
as I speak we've uploaded footage of the
call on Twitter you can watch it there
right now
in a moment we'll show you parts of it
in this video call Greg assumed the name
Chelsea Bussey he didn't dress up as a
woman he didn't wear any women's
clothing or makeup or any of that he
didn't go to Party City and dye his hair
blue he just told them he identified as
a woman and that he was taking hormones
prescribed by his father
Greg couldn't even pronounce the name of
the surgery he wanted he called it an
orchidectomy
he claimed at one point that the surgery
uh the reason he wanted the surgery is
that it would speed up his non-existent
transition which the plume nurse said
didn't make any sense from a medical
perspective but none of that raised any
red flags for plume
the nurse told Greg she wanted to write
him the strongest letter she could
anyway
watch
[Music]
are you taking uh 1.5 tablets yeah
history
all right
um
okay so let's let's kind of get into
this a little bit so you are seeking
what surgery
things in our ear of course you probably
are those things that aren't
irreversible when it comes to
um
estrogen-based therapy is breast
development and testicular shortage
right but there's always a possibility
for his room to come back that may that
may change in Orchestra
um you no longer have the ability for
your teeth to convert to BHT but you
don't have as much teeth right so hair
hair growth facial and body hair may
change
after organic food fat redistribution is
affected by the estrogate
so you may have less of a change in
Factory distribution if you ever stop e
but you may it may change as a whole so
it's it's kind of it's kind of um
it kind of does have a benefit without
the square lockdown but you still want
to take you still probably would
definitely want to take estrogen
I'm not I'm not complaining about the
daily pills just to be I'm complaining
I'm just saying if it accelerates it it
makes things faster than that's better
um give me a little bit of history with
your gender dysphoria that may kind of
help me I want to I want to make this
letter as as
solid as possible to be like
I'm happy to so when I was I was in
school and I actually uh wrote a big
essay
um for admission to a club about how I
didn't feel like my biological sex
went along with how I felt and and I
told people that and they thought it was
ridiculous so because I thought I just I
just look like a guy so they like this
this is ridiculous
no a couple of days after that
discussion as we document on Twitter
plume sent Greg a letter diagnosing him
with significant and ongoing gender
dysphoria therefore Plum said he was an
appropriate candidate for orchiectomy
according to plume testicle removal
would help Greg make significant
progress in alleviating his dysphoria
now even after Greg followed up with
text messages too plume explaining that
he doesn't have dysphoria they didn't
retract or amend that letter in any way
there's no excuse for that obviously
plume had multiple opportunities to tell
the truth in their letter and they chose
not to
in his intake form Greg indicated he
didn't have dysphoria for six months or
more didn't have it that means under the
current version of the DSM he never
should have been diagnosed with gender
dysphoria in the first place
but plume never once asked Greg about
this in his video interview
instead they just said that he had
dysphoria in the letter which they
intended to be used by a surgeon who
would then carve up Greg's testicles
why didn't plume amend the letter once
they were made aware that Greg didn't
have dysphoria
as plume's nurse explained in order for
the surgery to be paid for quote unquote
the diagnosis would need to remain in
other words insurance companies won't
pay for the operation unless the letter
contains a diagnosis of gender dysphoria
so they're going to put that diagnosis
in there regardless
that's why plume uses templates that
include the gender dysphoria diagnostic
code it appears very much so that they
plug whatever information patients feed
them into this generic template whether
or not those patients actually have the
diagnosis the templates are provided by
wpath by the way and plume admitted that
to us are you tired of breathing in
polluted air in the comfort of your own
home and want to safeguard your family's
health and well-being well with our new
friends at Enviro cleanse you'll never
have to worry again Enviro cleanse is an
in-home air purifying unit designed to
destroy cold and flu viruses allergy
inflaming toxins mold and even more with
Enviro cleanse they promise far fewer
colds allergies and better sleep they
even give you a free air quality monitor
to test the difference in your own home
Enviro cleanse sent us our own unit with
having six kids and a wife the last
thing any of us need is to get sick
because once one person gets sick it it
tears through the whole house and ruins
our week my kids want to be outside all
summer long and thanks to Enviro cleanse
we don't have to worry about getting
sick their air purifiers come in all
sizes colors and prices to fit every
budget they offer additional products
like Surface Cleaner and laundry
detergent so you can stay protected in
every aspect of your home breathe in
pure air and live a healthier life visit
ekpure.com and use code walls for 10 off
your Enviro cleanse home air
purification unit right now you'll also
get their free air quality monitor plus
fast free shipping that's a hundred and
fifty dollar savings ekpure.com code
Walsh that's ekpure.com promo code Welsh
it's not hard to conclude that this
operation is fraudulent but what do
insurers think of it what is Aetna and
uh United Health
think of it what's their position on
paying for surgeries based on cooked up
diagnostic codes what about Cigna
we understand those insurance companies
work directly with plume what about
David Sachs whose Venture Capital firm
is one of the many that's funding plume
what are his thoughts on this is he
aware this is happening
those are good questions
but the problem is much bigger than
plume that's what you have to understand
they're far from the only ones doing
this folks f-o-l-x for example is a
major competitor of plume they're in
almost every state in the country
they're also extremely well funded by
Venture capitalists folks like plume
also sells letters that authorize
surgeries under the wpath guidelines on
their website folks admits and I'm
quoting
it's quite possible that the information
in a letter may not be specific to you
for example they may use a gender
dysphoria diagnosis but you really do
not have dysphoria you may you may not
fit this diagnostic code exactly but in
some cases the code is needed in order
for insurers to pay for the surgery
now we reached out to folks to ask them
about this and they confirmed that a
diagnosis which they put in scare quotes
was necessary in order for insurance
companies to pay out
so that's why they put it in there
again that's probably news to the
insurance companies but the bigger issue
of course is what's happening to the
patients who are mutilated as part of
this process
it's not just plume and folks who are
authorizing surgeries like this there's
a whole network of doctors who crank out
these letters it's called the gender
affirmative letter Access Project or
Gallup
think of the lives that these doctors
and these companies are destroying for
profit
listen if they will approve Greg for
castration in 22 minutes
after he said he doesn't have dysphoria
they will approve anyone I mean anyone
many of The Luminaries in the field will
admit that by the way on Twitter we
highlighted this training session from
the Juniper Center which is one of the
largest gender therapy practices in the
Chicagoland area I want you to watch as
the licensed clinical social worker
named Erie Groner explains that she'll
rubber stamp whatever letter patients
want she said she'll even authorize a
suicidal patient for surgery because
she's not a gatekeeper in fact Runner
says that if her patient is suicidal
that that would make the case even
stronger for surgery listen to this
any psych history that might be helpful
to
sort of showing the necessity so if
let's say a client has a psych history
that includes like suicidal ideation or
a suicide attempt
and you can connect it to the gender
dysphoria that actually can be sort of a
positive
persuasive essay piece and I'll talk
about that in a little bit because you
can kind of show what this is so
necessary right this is how this is
impacting this person's life and this is
why this procedure is necessary and
needed I have found that when I frame it
in a you know we're going to kind of use
this as a persuasive essay and we're
going to really you know kind of Stick
it to them there's there's a little bit
more fun with it in the way we even use
language so I found that to kind of be
helpful with clients and who's asking us
to write these letters so oftentimes
we're we're being asked by surgeons or
Physicians but in reality it's really
for the insurance companies
um that's what the letters are really
for and I think that's important for us
to keep in mind
we have to
use the DSM in our letters for insurance
company so I'm not I'm not going to
spend a lot of time on this as y'all can
tell I'm not like the biggest DSM fan so
I just think it's important to highlight
because of this requirement and this is
something I'll explain to the client so
I'll talk about you know your insurance
company is saying as you know or sort of
a requirement for this letter for the
surgery that you have to have this
diagnosis and we'll kind of talk about
that
so
knowing that this you know sort of
American so Psychological Association or
DSM there's this history of
pathologizing and categorizing queer
people as sort of sexual deviants
there is that minimal Trust so
what I talk about is that we're using
the diagnosis to ensure that clients get
that necessary treatment
so these are letters that are necessary
to approve
life-altering mutilation procedures
and the people responsible for the
letters in this case this woman
describing them as persuasive essays
that she has fun with
now if you're defending gender affirming
care quote unquote for adults this is
what you're supporting you are saying
that it's reasonable for medical
professionals to listen to a suicidal
patient who isn't thinking clearly and
approve them for surgical castration
within minutes
you're saying there should be no
barriers to this kind of Mutilation
whatsoever
at that point why not bring back
lobotomies What's the serious principled
argument against it
no serious person can defend this injury
industry it's completely corrupted at
every level
it's not just targeting children
although it's certainly doing that as
well the underlying claims and Promises
of the entire gender affirming industry
are lies and they are lies propped up by
even more lies as we just showed you
and we'll have much more on wpath soon
by the way and how they became so
prominent in this field it's a truly
disturbing story
they're supposedly rigorous standards of
care are purpose built to be manipulated
as we've now revealed
a lot more on that
the Practical effect of these wpass
standards isn't to protect patients
instead the wpass standards protect
doctors who butcher their patients these
doctors understand that they need to
follow some kind of standard of care
quote-unquote or else they'll eventually
get sued into the ground for malpractice
by the patients they're disfiguring
so medical providers point to the wpath
standards and say look we follow the
standards these gruesome surgeries are
in fact legitimate Medical Care
now it's time to put an end to this
insurance insurance companies should cut
off these providers
investors should stop funding this
barbarism
and at the political level we need laws
so that any Doctor Who mutilates
patients or lies to insurance companies
goes to prison
regardless of the patient's age
Florida recently passed a law outlawing
among other things trans Telehealth
services that require in-person visits
for most of these procedures that's a
start which is why the media and trans
activists are Furious about it
they're probably going to sue to block
that portion of law just like they block
the part of the law outlying child
castration yesterday
but once people see the truth about
what's happening the radical gender
activists won't win that fight
that's why we published our
investigation today the truth is obvious
and undeniable
now that the standards of care have been
exposed for what they are there's
nothing to stop a flood of lawsuits that
could shut down these butchers
we saw it in the UK with Tavistock
if something like that happens here it
could save tens of thousands of lives
that's why this investigation is just
one part of what we have planned for
pride month we're going to expose the
full extent of the depravity that you're
told and insisted that you must believe
is medically legitimate
we're going to show you the truth behind
all the euphemisms we're going to reveal
how exactly activists have managed to
hijack the medical profession so they
can mutilate patients for profit
and this is just the beginning
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there